a newly released video is raising
questions about a company at the center
of a criminal investigation stemming
from the nation's opioid epidemic former
executives and managers for iNSYS
therapeutics are on trial in Boston
they're accused of bribing doctors to
prescribe a highly addictive
fentanyl spray federal prosecutors
allege the company used a music video to
motivate employees to push sales of the
medication tonita copal is following a
trial Tony good morning good morning
those former incest executives and
managers are charged with conspiring
with one another to use bribes and
kickbacks for doctors who wrote large
numbers of prescriptions the video shown
in court yesterday is now just one piece
of mounting evidence in the case
prosecutors say this 5-minute rap video
debuted at an incest sales conference in
2015 in it two young salesmen promote
the powerful fentanyl spray subsys the
message encouraged incest sales
representatives to push doctors to
increase the strength of substance
prescriptions until a patient reaches
the adequate dosage it's a process known
as titration
prosecutors say the person wearing the
substance costume labelled with the
medication highest dosage his incest is
former Vice President of Sales Alec
Birla cough in November Birla cough
pleaded guilty in the nationwide
conspiracy to bribe doctors to prescribe
substance
he's expected to testify as a government
witness in 2017 CBS News learned incest
made 18 thousand payments to doctors the
year before that totaled more than two
million dollars on resource on secures
claimed incest founder John Kapur
personally recruited physicians for a
kickback scheme which included dinners
at high-end restaurants and payments for
sham speaking engagements Kapoor's
attorney has claimed he's innocent
they've made allegations about different
marketing and sales techniques by the
company he was not involved in that at
all since the Food and Drug
Administration approved subsys in 2012
to treat severe cancer pain incest has
reportedly disclosed more than 900
substance related deaths to the FDA
incest therapeutics has told CBS News it
is cooperating with authorities and is
committed to complying with all laws and
regulations that apply no new wraps or
rhymes this morning yeah it's very
disturbing and when you look at that rap
video in context with this story there's
nothing cute about that
it seems inappropriate it really does
thank you very much Tony to Coco